look around
you will be fine
[Music]
that was you'll be found from the hit
Broadway show
dear Evan Hanson sung by fans all over
the world
the musical touches on a difficult topic
but one that deserves our attention the
recent deaths of fashion designer Kate
Spade and celebrity chef Anthony
Bourdain but a focus on the problem of
suicide in this country the Netflix
series thirteen reasons why stirred
controversy when it was blamed for
possibly inspiring suicides but
remarkably dear Evan Hansen's been
credited with the opposite helping fans
cope with issues that can lead to
depression jamie wax is here to explain
Jamie good morning good morning Anthony
less than two years since its Broadway
premiere dear Evan Hansen continues a
radical experiment using a musical to
address the issues of depression and
suicide it's got a chart-topping
original cast album and six Tony Awards
but the show is also hailed for a
realistic and constructive approach to
an issue that ails so many did you
foresee this piece having such a huge
impact when you began your work on it
everybody that we told the idea to
thought that we were insane and was very
polite about it but it just doesn't
sound like a musical and it didn't sound
like something that people thought had
any kind of commercial viability and the
Tony Award goes to
dear Evan Hansen the success of dear
Evan Hansen caught everybody by surprise
including playwright Steven Levinson who
created the musical along with the
oscar-winning songwriting team binge
PASOK and Justin Paul
[Music]
it tells the story of an unlikely bond
between the socially anxious and
isolated high school senior Evan Hansen
[Music]
and the family coping with the suicide
of Evans classmate Connor Murphy it's
anything but your typical Broadway
blockbuster but according to Levinson
what the audience found in this show and
appreciated was a sense of authenticity
I think it's about empowering people and
letting them know that there is help and
that there are people that are there to
listen and as cheesy as that sounds it's
true that message began resonating with
audiences well before its success on
Broadway Rachael Bay Jones received a
Tony for her role as Evans mother Heidi
when we did early productions even early
readings and workshops the people who
came there responded in such an
emotionally visceral way that it was
clear that this is going to make an
impact on a lot of people
[Music]
Taylor Trench currently plays the role
of Evan Hansen I got like piles of
letters every week from people who have
gone through experiences similar to
Evans or to Connors and it is
eye-opening to see people feel safe
writing it and how widespread it is Alex
Boniello plays Connor Murphy whose
character takes his own life at the
beginning of the musical how does
dear Evan Hansen stay so true and in
many ways so sharply brutally honest
about different things and not
glamorized the issue of suicide yeah
it's you know it's so fascinating
because it's something that I've been
thinking a lot about there's a lyric
that my character sings and it's if you
never get around to doing some
remarkable thing that doesn't mean that
you're not worth remembering if you
never get around to doing some
remarkable thing that doesn't mean that
you're not worse remember when we look
at someone like Anthony Bourdain or Kate
Spade these are people who have changed
millions of lives and it still can't
always fix or change whatever is going
on that's causing the the terrible
issues for you but to know that you're
not alone and that your life is worth
something always you don't have to be
extraordinary to be lovable that's right
that's right you know you're not alone
you will be found
[Music]
when the show premiered on Broadway at
the end of 2016
suicide rates were at a 30-year high
it's the second leading cause of death
and people aged 10 to 20 for the fourth
leading cause in those between 35 and 54
while nearly 9% of those 18 to 25
admitted to having suicidal thoughts we
had no idea that the show would start
the conversations that it started and
we're not experts we quickly learned
from the experts what to say and where
to guide people and how to get people to
the right places if they needed help
those early moves to kind of partner
with those people and to get that
conversation started we're very
beneficial to the show and kept us
honest and kept us knowing the
responsibility that we had early on the
show teamed up with a number of advocacy
and suicide prevention groups including
the child mind Institute and the JED
foundation first for guidance with the
script then for ongoing support as an
expert who's worked in this field your
entire life when you first saw the
musical was there something in you that
said yes this story's gonna help people
yes absolutely
I saw how affected the audience was and
it was clear that it was really sort of
speaking to people in a very deep way
dr. Victor Schwartz is the jet
foundation's chief medical officer
they've continued to be directly
involved with the production you've
actually done as an organization a
number of interventions connected to his
show yes we have is it overstating it to
say that dear Evan Hanson has saved
lives
no I don't think so we're at a time
where there have been several
high-profile suicides recently is there
a takeaway in your experience and about
how we should be talking about this so
much of my response is just as a
storyteller we always knew from a pretty
early moment we want the audience to
walk away feeling like these characters
are going to be ok and the most powerful
thing that I remember was
been flat when he was in the show he got
a letter sent to his dressing room
anonymously that said because of you I
didn't let go we get so many thousands
and thousands of letters I'm telling you
that there are so many similarities in
all of them that that one thing alone
has given me more hope strangely
thousands of people writing in saying
they've been touched I felt this way I
did this my family is like this and to
me that's not gives me so much heart and
so much hope because we aren't alone
right interconnectedness is humanity and
if you're in need of that message of
hope but you can't make it to New York
to see the show on Broadway that
grammy-winning cast album is available
wherever you purchase music or stream it
and the show begins its national tour in
Denver in September I love this show I
know you didn't I love this you were
there Ben Platts last night was I've
seen it four times I took each one of my
kids separately to see it it's it is a
brilliant musical with an incredible a
really difficult subject so well bench
passuk and Justin Paul who wrote the
score also wrote greatest showmen learns
in la-la land
incredible just it's incredible show if
you can get to new york get a ticket any
way you can I love it
you know we focus on the message of the
show a lot in this piece but actually
going back and looking at it through the
eyes of this research
it really doesn't cut corners creatively
it's a it doesn't pull punches it deals
with real edge and some brutality with
the issues that it has but that message
of hope and humanity is really central
to other things are so interesting being
in the audience for it is you see the
range of Ages and how it touches
everybody it's a family show in that it
touches you know parents and kids it
really every anybody can relate to it
it's just so brilliant and the team
behind it seems surprised at the amount
of letters they get from people who have
struggled I think they are and I and I
think very early on when the show is
running off-broadway they realized from
the response of people and the fact that
people wanted to stick around and talk
about it that they really needed to do
more powerful stuff Jamie thanks so much
thank you